l'adf on a vu la définition des
probabilités conditionnelles à partir de
laquelle on a démontré la formule de
pays et je suis allé un peu vite donc je
vous ai peut-être un petit peu fait peur
rassurez vous aujourd'hui on va prendre
le temps de disséquer cette merveilleuse
équation pour essayer de comprendre
autant que possible ce qu'elle nous dit
car cette équation qui en fait
énormément de choses et a de nombreuses
conséquences assez stupéfiante sur ce
qu'est un raisonnement correct alors
tout d'abord on peut s'arrêter sur le
terme de gauche et s'il est tout seul à
gauche c'est vraiment parce qu'il s'agit
du terme le plus important ce terme
à gauche c'est la probabilité de la
théorie t sachant les données d alors le
mot probabilités et si un petit peu
étrange que peut bien signifier la
probabilité d'une théorie est sa
probabilité d'être vrai peut-on vraiment
parler de la probabilité que quelque
chose soit vrai sachant qu'il ne s'agit
absolument pas d'un lancer de dés n'est
ce pas hasardeuse de laisser le statut
d'une théorie au hasard
il est intéressant de noter que le
langage des probabilités ne nous dit pas
comment interpréter cette quantité à
gauche
il affirme seulement que sachant les
données des chaque théorie est associé à
un nombre ici représentée par les
symboles paix entre crochets tesla
racheter et que ce nombre est calculé
par la formule 2 bis alors pas tout à
fait le langage des probabilités nous
dit un peu plus que cela nous dit via la
loi des probabilités total dont on a
parlé la dernière fois que si l'on doit
prédire la probabilité d'un événement x
sachant les données b alors il faut
calculer les prédictions de différentes
théories t et prendre la moyenne de ces
prédictions pondérée par les
probabilités des théories t sachant des
romans dit la formule dans laquelle paix
de thé bardet est utilisée suggère que
paie de thé bardet ne doit pas tant être
interprétée comme la probabilité de la
théorie t sachant d il semble qu'il
faille davantage interprété comme le
degré de confiance qu'il faut attribuer
à la théorie t sachant dès lorsqu'il
s'agit de faire des prédictions
notamment relativement haut degré de
confiance a assigné aux théories
alternatives et plutôt que de parler de
degré de confiance qui est une
expression un petit peu longue
dorénavant et à l'instar de ce que j'ai
fait dans mon livre je parlerai de la
crédence de la théorie t sachant les
données d ainsi il me semble que
l'interprétation minimaliste de là
formule de belize nous invite à
considérer que l'objet central d'études
du bail à nice mme et la crédence des
théories étant donné des données
collectées puis s'est créé danse
pourront être utilisés pour effectuer
des prédictions probabiliste mais je
vais laisser l'aspect prédictifs de côté
pour aujourd'hui
nora largement l'occasion d'y revenir il
y aura aussi pas mal de subtilité a
détaillé concernant ce qu'on entend ici
pardonner est ce qu'une fée qui nous est
une donnée est ce qu'un lapsus est une
donnée est ce qu'un bug informatique est
une donnée bien la réponse de base
et oui même si c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça mais en tout cas en
première approximation toute information
reçue est une donnée et doit être prise
en compte par la formule le pays
en fait il faudrait même idéalement
considérer la liste d' absolument toutes
les données qui existent y compris les
photos de bébés les a priori elle ne
devrait pas franchement modifié
évoquerez dansant la relativité générale
mais on ne sait jamais ok à 20 sont pas
sont à comment on calcule la crédence
d'une théorie le premier terme à droite
et la probabilité des données sachant la
théorie c'est ce que les statisticiens
notamment les statisticiens fréquentes
east appelle la vraisemblance pour ceux
qui en ont entendu parler
la fameuse paix value dont on parlera
longuement est une espèce de
vraisemblance déguisé cependant et je ne
peux insisté suffisamment dessus il est
crucial
je répète crucial de garder en tête que
la vraisemblance des données n'est pas
la crédence de la théorie je le répète
la crédence de la théorie et pour en
savoir plus
hygiène mentale à une excellente vidéo
sur cette distinction en faite
d'expériences notamment personnel n'est
pas que la terminologie vraisemblance
porte énormément à confusion
surtout dès qu'il s'agit du maximum de
vraisemblance non le maximum de
vraisemblance n'est quasiment jamais la
théorie à poux crédible le maximum de
vraisemblance est la théorie qui
maximise la vraisemblance des données
sachant la théorie mais la vraisemblance
des données n'est pas la crédence de la
théorie pour éviter les confusions ainsi
que pour mieux comprendre ces termes de
vraisemblance des données je préfère les
appeler terme d'expérience de penser car
c'est vraiment ça qui exige ce terme
ils demandent de supposer que la théorie
est vrai aidé ensuite d
armin et la probabilité d'observer les
données observées
autrement dit ce terme nous invite à
imaginer un monde alternatif où l'on
sait à 100% que la théorie t est vrai
dans ce monde alternatif les données
observées sont elles ce à quoi on
pouvait s'attendre
ou bien sont elles surprenante on
insistera davantage sur cette notion de
surprise dans les expériences de pensée
dans les prochaines vidéos parce qu'elle
est vraiment vraiment cruciale
mais pour l'heure j'aimerais insister
sur un autre point la théorie t doit
assigner une quantité de surprise ou
donner des ou dit autrement la théorie
doit absolument être prédictive mais pas
prédictifs dans le sens où elle prédit
de données précises non la théorie doit
effectuer des prédictions probabiliste à
l'instar des prédictions de facteurs
tiède sur un politique de kickoff points
et aillent sur les matches de football
ou de sites jpy gré sur l'avenir du bric
site
la théorie doit paris ça ça peut
paraître étrange car de nombreuses
théories scientifiques ne font pas du
tout de telles paris la relativité
générale ne semble pas parier sur
l'issue du match france argentine ni
même sur la présence de trous noirs dans
notre univers en fait la relativité
générale seule n'est tout simplement pas
prédictive comme l'expliquent très bien
tivo dans cette vidéo elle doit
s'accompagner d' hypothèse auxiliaires
typiquement les états physiques probable
de l'univers pour devenir une théorie
prédictive par exemple sachant la
relativité générale et sachant les
histoires probable de l'univers serait
ton surpris de découvrir l'existence de
trous noirs
de nos jours les astrophysiciens
répondre est quasi unanimement non la
théorie relativité générale + histoire
probable de l'univers tel qu on le
comprend aujourd'hui est bien prédictive
au sens bayésiens au moins dans le
domaine de la cosmologie sur la question
de l'existence des trous noirs
elles semblent parier aujourd'hui très
probablement oui
ainsi plus généralement les théories
étudié par le belize à nice mme ne
peuvent pas être des lois physiques
isolés ou des principes comme c'est la
faute aux aliens
elles doivent s'efforcer d'assigner des
probabilités à toutes sortes
d'événements s'agit là d'un point
crucial sur lequel on reviendra plus
longuement plus tard dans cette série
bref il y aurait bien plus à dire sur le
terme d'expérience de penser comme le
fait qu un sophisme très récurrent et le
refus du calcul des termes d'expérience
de pensée pour des théories qui ne nous
plaisent pas et le temps passe et je
propose de passer aux termes suivants de
l'expression le terme suivant est
vraiment le terme le plus controversé de
la formule deux pays c'est la
probabilité de la théorie lorsqu'on ne
connaît pas les données d on parle de
crédence a priori avant de découvrir les
données par opposition au terme de
gauche qui est donc la crédence a
posteriori postérieur c'est à dire après
avoir découvert les données pendant très
longtemps et encore aujourd'hui selon
beaucoup la présence de ces a priori
dans le boys and his mme est la raison
pour laquelle le bail à nice mme est
nécessairement fallacieux il s'agit même
à en croire certains d'un axiome des
sciences que d'atteindre des conclusions
sans a priori
du reste je suis en train de parler d'à
priori mais on peut bien voir que ce
terme technique est en fête synonyme du
mot préjugés surtout quand on prend le
mot préjugés au sens littéral
oui parce que étymologiquement préjugés
signifie jugé avant typiquement avant
d'accéder aux données des et donc la
peur by then veut nous faire croire que
pour penser juste il faudrait s'appuyer
sur nos préjugés et bien oui
selon la pure bayésienne un raisonnement
n'est juste que s'il est conforme aux
lois des probabilités
il ne peut être conforme aux lois des
probabilités que s'il s'appuie sur un
préjugé
le baiia nisme impose de faire des
préjugés
l'un des piliers du savoir alors dit
comme ça ça peut paraître maintenant
assez bizarre car le mot préjugés a
souvent une connotation très négative et
c'est super important de prêter
attention à la manière dont on utilise
et réagit à ces connotations est donc
juste pour équilibrer les choses je
pourrais remplacer le mot préjugés par
un synonyme à connotation positive comme
l'état actuel des connaissances
donc au final le bail à nice mme dit
tout bêtement que l'état actuel des
connaissances est indispensable pour
bien pensé et là tout de suite ça vous
paraît sans doute moins choquant mais je
préfère insister sur la première version
à coups de préjugés pour deux raisons la
première c'est qu'en tant que base et
enthousiaste il me faut faire super
gaffe à ne pas induire en erreur pour de
mauvaises raisons et pour lutter contre
mon biais de confirmation il est
préférable de défendre une version
péjorative de ce que je défends et puis
ça évitera aussi que vous soyez
convaincus pour de mauvaises raisons
la deuxième raison pour laquelle je vais
utiliser le mot préjugés c'est que
parler de préjugés me semble plus
instructif
car ça re met davantage en question nous
approche intuitive du savoir et de
l'épistémologie voir comme on ne cessera
de le voir le plus gros obstacle à
penser mieux c'est bien souvent notre
excès de confiance en notre savoir et
notre approche du savoir me semble
important de secouer un peu le cocotier
et de se rendre compte régulièrement des
innombrables faille de nos raisonnements
intuitif et des méthodes usuellement
défendu et remettre régulièrement en
question le fait que les préjugés sont
néfastes à bien penser me semble un pas
très utile pour questionner tout
l'édifice du savoir bref aussi étrange
que cela puisse paraître
selon la pure bélizienne il faut des
préjugés en fait c'est même sans doute
la première étape à réaliser si possible
avant même de découvrir les données il
nous faut explicitement décrire nos
préjugés c'est à dire ce qui paraît
plausible et ce qui paraît moins
plausible eu égard aux données et même
quantifier les crédences à avoir en les
diverses théories avant d'observer les
données et c'est pour ça que je vous
invite régulièrement à parier notamment
à travers mes hashtag paribas lien sur
twitter ou sur les résultats du sondage
de michael décrivez vos préjugés
quels sont les résultats auxquels vous
vous attendez quels sont les résultats
qui vous surprendrai et à quel point
êtes-vous confiant en vos préjugés
alors au début tout ça c'est super
perturbant mais en fait un principe
souvent mise en avant qui correspond
exactement 1 tels préjugés à savoir le
fameux rasoir d'occam celui ci dit en
gros cas performance prédictive égal il
faut préférer les théories plus simple
autrement dit toutes les théories ne se
valent pas a priori selon de nombreux
scientifiques philosophes et
esthéticiens il s'agit d'un bon préjugés
que de penser que les théories plus
simples sont plus crédibles et on
reviendra bien sûr longuement sur tout
ça parce qu'il ya beaucoup plus à dire
comme notamment faire la différence
entre un bon et un mauvais préjugés
enfin il ya le dénominateur aussi appelé
marginal ou fonction de partitions le
nom importe peu mais sachez que ce
dénominateur est un monstre surtout d'un
point de vue calculatoire en fait vient
souvent c'est vraiment ce monstre qui
rend le calcul de la formule 2 bis
impossible en pratique il ya même des
conférences de recherche dont le seul
but est de trouver des façons de
calculer rapidement d'assez bonne
approximation que c'est cette fonction
de partitions et pourtant cette fonction
de partitions nous dit quelque chose de
tout bête
nous dit tout simplement que pour savoir
si la théorie tes mérites nos crédence
il faut il suffit de la comparer aux
théories alternatives à autrement dit
selon la pure bayésienne la clé danse
d'une théorie n'est que relative au
crédit danse des théories alternatives
en particulier une théorie assez simple
qui explique presque toutes les données
pourraient néanmoins être peu crédible
notamment s'il existe une alternative
encore plus simple capable de super bien
expliquer toutes les données et on a
d'ailleurs déjà parlé d'un exemple
bluffant de cela qui explique pourquoi
einstein était convaincu de la
relativité générale avant toute
confirmation empirique
à l'inversé les théories les plus
crédibles pour expliquer un phénomène
complexe pourrait être en fait des
théories qui n'explique pas super bien
le phénomène en question
il suffit pour cela qu'aucune
alternative suffisamment simples ne
parviennent à faire mieux ça dans des
domaines ultra complexes comme
l'économie les sciences sociales et les
prédictions sur le futur désir ça arrive
en fait tout le temps dans ces domaines
les meilleurs théorie non pas être à la
fois simple et à parvenir à tout
expliquer tout simplement car aucune
théorie simple ne semble y arriver de
façon générale les théories les plus
crédibles ne colleront général non pas
aux données mais ça normalement vous
devriez déjà le savoir puisque on en a
déjà longuement parlé dans la série sur
lire oui parce que donner trop de crédit
aux théories trop complexe qui peut le
donner
c'est s'exposer un lover fitting aussi
appelé la surinterprétation et en
pratique on observe empiriquement que
c'est très clairement le cas en termes
prédictif les meilleurs théorie ne sont
pas celles qui expliquent à 100% les
données collectées
il est même souvent souhaitable de
n'accorder du crédit qu'à des théories
grossière et dont l'explication des
données observées n'est que très
partielle surtout dans des cas
d'applications complexes comme la bourse
la météo le football
bon voilà je pense qu'on peut s'arrêter
pour là pour aujourd'hui
même s'il y aura bien sûr beaucoup plus
à dire la vidéo commence à être un peu
longue
j'espère toutefois vous avoir donné une
idée d'à quel point cette formule
fantastique était fondamental et tout ce
qu'elle nous dit du savoir et de
l'épistémologie ans pourtant si peu de
caractère
j'espère que vous commencez à comprendre
pourquoi j'ose l'appeler la formule du
savoir sans sourciller
pourquoi c'est devenu mon équation
préféré des mathématiques et comment un
si petit nombre de symboles a pu ne
cessez de me tenir en haleine et excité
mes neurones au cours des trois
dernières années et je vous invite à
longuement la méditer vous aussi et a
essayé d'écouter tout ce qu'elle a à
vous dire comme par exemple au sujet des
deux enfants en fait pour comprendre le
bail à nice mme et progresser dans votre
appréhension de votre appréhension du
monde hashtag l'état de bêta
je vous le recommande vivement la
méditation régulière de la formule de bx
disons au moins deux fois par jour
j'espère que vous avez aimé cette vidéo
à propos de mon équation préféré des
mathématiques quelques annonces dans les
deux semaines à venir je vais être très
très occupés notamment demain et après
demain je serai à polygone à lyon donc
les 5 et 6 mars pour parler
dia et notamment de ce que les sciences
sociales peuvent contribuer à notamment
la sécurité et d'éthique d'hésiode parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de travail à faire à
l'interface possèdent ou même le samedi
9 mars je serai à lausanne pour un
workshop organisé par effective
altruisme lausanne
ce sera un workshop introductif à
l'altruisme efficace si vous êtes
notamment autour de lausanne par exemple
au hasard à le pfl ou à l'unil ma pensée
à venir nous voir ce sera un événement
très sympa ce sera l'occasion
d'introduire un peu les idées attributs
cassé puis de son encontre et non c'est
toujours très sympa dans ce genre de
trucs
ensuite la semaine suivante le lundi 11
mars je serai à metz pour le mess data
week où je parlerai de rendre les ja
bénéfique avec un angle très
statistiques on parlera notamment des
problèmes
statistiques à ses fondamentaux qui lui
a par rapport à la sécurité d
intelligence artificielle et des axes de
recherche me semble important de
développer ensuite le mardi 12 mars à
18h30 je serai un peu et techniques alix
pour le lancement de l'altruisme
efficace polytechnique où on va faire
une introduction à l'atrium efficace
aussi je parlerai des plans de carrière
a un impact qui sont qui ont été en tout
cas identifiés par le mouvement
altruisme efficace ensuite le jeudi 14
mars je serai en live sur la chaîne de
string theory donc jeudi soir je sais
pas quelle heure exactement mais bon
voilà jeudi soir et le samedi 16 mars je
commençais vers 17h15 quelque chose
comme ça je serai à la chaux de fonds en
suisse pour le festival ludesco autour
des jeux de société vous donnera une
conférence autour notamment des
mathématiques du jeu du loup garou voir
ça fait mal des dates tu vas avoir des
semaines
ultra chargé si vous voulez suivre mon
actualité plus généralement essayer
d'anticiper les prochains truc parce
qu'ils ont encore plein de choses qui
vont venir notamment en avril puis en
mai puis en juin
j'ai mis en lien dans la description
d'un document où je mets régulièrement
un jour les prochaines dates des
prochains événements auxquels je
participe notamment des conférences que
je donne vous pourrez trouver ça dans
les descriptions l1 fois on avait parlé
des lois des probabilités on avait
démontré le théorème de belz à partir
des lois des probabilités et j'avais
commencé a déjà introduit cette notion
d'à priori préjugés qui est utile pour
raisonner de façon probabiliste et
jonathan châtaignes nous demandent
comment est-ce qu'on peut appliquer sa
peau cas notamment de la tente d'un bus
qui est un peu de façon de juger
combien de temps on va attendre un bus
notamment parlant de sa chambre des
raisons dure cinq minutes après lara
approche consiste à supposer que les bus
arrivent intervalles de temps réguliers
que du coup le temps d'attentes de
quelqu'un alors ce qui attend le bus est
une distribution uniforme
ou entre 0 et lt et le temps de passage
entre deux bus successifs d'autres
approches dont on parle souvent c'est à
considérer qu'il s'agit d'une loi
exponentielle c'est à dire que peu
importe le temps que nous a attendu on
doit s'attendre à attendra le même même
quantité de temps avant le prochain
juste on pourrait même rajouter une
autre loi qui est la loi puissance qui
correspondra à dire que plus on a tendu
le bus que plus on a de chances de
devoir l'attendre longtemps au cas des
grèves
finalement il ya pas mal de distribution
imaginables donc laquelle le choisir en
tant que préjugés et bien il faut bien
son tour qu'en pratique au 15e c'est
cette distribution classique qui sont
faciles à tuer parce que ce sont des
lois de propriété très facile à écrire
notamment et bien manipuler aucune de
ces lois a priori ne s'était vraiment à
la pratique ya pas mal d'autres choses à
prendre en compte notamment est ce que
c'est un jour de grève pour pouvoir
choisir au mieux ses préjugés et
globalement il faut faire attention dans
ce genre de situation à ne pas se
comporter en dr jon k
c'est à dire à identifier seulement un
petit nombre de modèles qui
correspondent à la réalité et faire une
surinterprétation sur ses modèles faire
trop confiance à ces modèles est négligé
des distributions de probabilité qui ne
font pas partie de l'ensemble des
distributions considérer reparlera bien
sûr de tout ça lorsqu'on parlera
notamment de solomon expertise avec
cette vidéo la prochaine fois on va
appliquer enfin la formule de bs pour
voir comment est-ce qu'on raisonne de
façon visuelle en pratique on a eu la
formule encore mieux comment être une
pique vraiment qu'on pratique et on
appliquera tout ça notamment au fameux
poème du monde où je vous parlerai de la
solution parisienne du moutier qui n'a
heureusement pas si souvent présentés
tels contrôles de vidéos youtube qui
présentait vraiment cette solution
béziers ou youtube
vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à la
ligue et a commencé à les partager pour
ses abonnés pour bloquer les épisodes
noirs ce type erp et lardons et j'espère
que vous serez là la prochaine fois si
on part de l'hypothèse qu'elle est
innocente deux morts subites du
nourrisson d'affilée ce serait trop
invraisemblable une chance sur 73
millions
on en déduit donc que on peut rejeter
l'hypothèse de son innocence
et dans l'hypothèse où elle est
réellement coupable et bien c'est sûr
que les victimes sont mortes
c'est 100% si j'utilise le schéma que
j'ai présentées dans l'épisode précédent
je place horizontalement les différentes
vraisemblance écrit comme ça ça a l'air
vite vu mais en vérité ce n'est pas
exactement ces chiffres là qu'il nous
faut nous faire une opinion sur la
culpabilité
si on raisonne de façon bayésienne il
faut plutôt calculer la probabilité
qu'elle soit coupable d'infanticide
sachant que ces deux bébés sont morts
vous voyez celle inverse
ça c'est la plausibilité de sa
culpabilité b